et sur le mariage homosexuel qu'on a
appelé le mariage pour tous évidemment
ça pose bien la question qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire maintenant est ce qu'il vaut
mieux assumer sa différence son identité
dans son entreprise se revendiquer d'une
certaine manière ou bien vivre sa
sexualité sans en parler et chercher une
forme d'indifférence voilà des puits que
doit faire l'entreprise aussi parce
qu'elle doit en parler ce qu'elle doit
intervenir notamment dans les conflits
de tout ça on va parler avec nos invités
avec marlies de me landre qui signent
donc ce communisme merci d'être avec
nous avec le député a one binet élus de
l'isère et rapporteur de la loi sur le
mariage homosexuel
catherine tripon l'une des figures de la
lutte pour les droits des homosexuels en
france d'être directrice diversité de la
fondation phase qui est une fondation
créée par des entreprises contre
l'exclusion et militants de l'autre
cercle qui défend les homosexuels au
travail christophe falck aux consultants
en ressources humaines et gestion de
carrière vous c'est le management est
professeur à l'iae lyon qui est une
école de management spécialiste
notamment des discriminations enfin
thierry laurent économiste professeur à
l'université d'evry val d'essonne vous
venez de publier une étude sur le coût
d'un coming out
le coût d'un communisme coming out dont
on connaît le connaît le mot c'est
sortir du placard il ya eu un film
fameux là-dessus révélait donc son
homosexualité
marlyse de meulan pourquoi avoir appelé
ce film comme une hymne en dise encore
entre le coming out effectivement termes
assez connu exide et l'inclusion en
entreprise le in il y avait un jeu de
mot entre être in et être à haute et
dont l'idée de ce film c'est d'aller
voir quand même ce qui se passe dans les
entreprises et fait quoi l'inclusion et
plus largement dans le monde du travail
et comment lengue finalement trouvent
leur place et leur identité au travail
l'inclusion c'est un terme qui est pas
mal utilisés dans les politiques
diversité en entreprise
en fait ça relève de la politique
diversité et le point de vue est de
pouvoir accueillir tous les salariés
quel que soit leurs critères un petit
peu ce père sans qui la communauté du
truck series avant qu'on soit qu'elles
soient ces pratiques quelle que soit la
couleur de peau pénalisé de l'inclusion
oui d'accord quel a été le déclencheur
du documentaire la loi sur le mariage
homosexuel alors plusieurs choses
à la fois une prise de conscience
personnelle et qui date d'il ya plus de
dix ans parce qu'il ya disons une
collègue de travail qui est ensuite
devenue une amie m'a révélé son
homosexualité
sous le sceau du secret on va dire après
qu'on travaille au travail après
quelques années partagées au travail et
du coup ça m'a amené à vraiment
interrogées cette chose là effectivement
et elle m'a dit à l'époque mais tu ne te
rends pas compte du risque qui peut y
avoir pour une personne gay ou lesbienne
a révélé ce quelle est son identité au
travail et effectivement quand on est
dans la norme petit majoritaire on ne
s'en rend pas compte de ce qui peut être
vécu et moi j'avais du coup ont vite de
renverser le miroir et d'aller voir et
d'interroger donc
des gays et des lesbiennes sur leur
quotidien de vie au travail qui sont des
militants ce qu'on entend dans le feu du
non sont pas des militants alors il se
trouve que l'un de ses personnages a
pris la tête après avoir vécu cachée
dans son entreprise pendant cinq ans il
a finalement fait son coming out et il a
pris la tête d'un programme mais qui est
un programme bénévoles on va dire
d'inclusion sera content et il le
raconte et pour le reste ce sont des
gens ordinaires le routard et ça mais
qui ont dévoilé leur homosexualité oui
bien sûr avant le film bien sûr oui pour
les uns pas son coming out dans un film
d'art que quoi que ce n'est pas le cas
pourquoi pas laisser perdre non ils sont
pas tous militants engagés associatif
non absolument pas ça a été facile pour
eux de de témoigner et pour vous de les
convaincre de témoigner non ça n'a pas
été si facile
j'ai pas mal travaillé en lien avec des
associations lgbt
lesbienne gay bi et trans parce que ça
existe dans l'entreprise on pourrait
s'en étonner effectivement le monde du
travail est un monde qui a été un monde
d'invisibilité structurelles pour pour
les gays et les lesbiennes une
invisibilité structurelles et
d'illégitimité pour ce sujet c'est à
dire il n'était pas question parler
d'homosexualité au travail pour un tas
de raisons s'étaient renvoyé à la sphère
privée du coup à partir des années 2000
des associations sont créés pour
accompagner les gens parce que bien
consciente de la difficulté dans les
entreprises en temps les entreprises ou
en inde il ya d'homosexuels intérêts
l'inter entreprise ou dans les
entreprises elles mêmes comme cela se
passe aux etats unis pas comme ça se
passe au monde anglo saxon mais
exactement ouais ouais c'est ça et donc
je suis passé par l'intermédiaire de
cessation de ces associations lgbt
je les ai toutes rencontrées ou à peu
près en face elles toutes celles qui
relèvent de deux grands groupes de
grandes entreprises françaises pour
certaines internationale en leur
demandant de travailler à mes côtés pour
pour rencontre ne serait-ce que
rencontrer des gens essayaient dé
convaincre voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
été amené à rencontrer un certain nombre
de personnes mais je pense que c'est
encore une prise de risque pour certains
y compris pour ceux qui ont déjà dévoilé
leur homosexualité votera oui parce que
parce qu'il ya des coming out qui sont
des comiques sélectif je veux dire le
dira quelques collègues en qui on a
confiance n'est pas le dire à son
supérieur hiérarchique c'est pas le dire
à son grand patron et c'est encore moins
le dire devant une caméra qu'une cause
de souffrance même pour cela qu'ils ont
l'air d'assumer tous sont passés par des
états et des moments de remise en
question oui bien sûr on entend et et
c'est cette sensibilité cette
sensibilité là en même temps qu'il est
intéressant de l'entendre
erwann binet
après la loi du mariage pour tous on en
est encore là où à cause de la loi
mariage pour tous on est encore là on
sait pas on en discutera tout à l'heure
mais on en est encore là en tout cas en
2015 est ce qu'on connaît le nombre
d'homosexuels qui en entreprise se
dévoile est ce qu'on connaît cette
proportion non je suis pas sûr qu'il ait
des statistiques là dessus et puis en
plus le fait de se dévoiler appartient
est une décision qui appartient à chacun
d'entre eux
elle est d'entre eux
le ton du documentaire est entièrement à
l'imparfait au passé
ce qui est intéressant ça donne l'idée
qu'il ya eu un avant et un après
peut-être après le mariage pour tous
avec on le voit bien d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire c'est le paroxysme dans le
débat et même dans dans l'expression de
l'homophobie en même temps des
situations comme elles sont décrites ici
il en existe encore aujourd'hui après le
débat la seule chose qui change c'est
que d'abord la loi reconnaît le couple
homosexuel officiellement même titre et
john cale et addictions par la loi
c'est ma surprise pardonnez moi ma ma
grande surprise en voyant ce
documentaire c'est de me dire mais enfin
on dit quand même qu'on met un cas
presque quinze ans après le pacs et on
en est encore à se cacher je crois qu'on
a les chiffres d'ailleurs vous avez le
chiffre catherine tripon et puis 67% et
de l'autre et une enquête qui avait
commandité christophe pour la halde on
était entre 60 ans palle avait tiré tout
à l'heure entre 74 et 75 % donc plus des
deux tiers des homosexuels et lesbiennes
aujourd'hui se cachant dû se cache vous
employer le mot se cache on se casse çà
ne se dévoile pas ne parle pas leur vie
privée ne répondent pas qu'ils sont cons
leur pelouse mais c'était ce qu'on a
c'est scandaleux et on espère évidemment
que les chiffres vont baisser en même
temps l'entreprise est une micro société
et une microsociété donc vous ne pouvez
pas partir sauf à démissionner et
évidemment vous êtes libres d'y apporter
votre personnalité tous les aspects de
votre personnalité ou pas dans cette
microsociété il doit y avoir autant
d'homophobe ou de gens ayant
une ne serait ce que pendant un match
pour tous des remarques extrêmement
négative vis-à-vis de ce projet de loi
et dans toutes les cellules de la
société à ce moment là on a évoqué ce
sujet dans toutes les entreprises à la
machine à café ça et c'est évidemment un
sujet on le voit d'ailleurs à travers le
témoignage du gendarme y compris dans
les gendarmeries
voilà et donc c'est une microsociété de
laquelle on ne peut pas partir librement
ce qui change c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
loi dit les couples homosexuels les
familles homosexuelles sont des familles
à part entière sont des couples à part
entière ce qui change les choses et par
ailleurs il n'y avait pas de documents
officiels avant que vous produisiez dans
laquelle on pouvait juger de votre
homosexualité votre pacs vous le
produisiez pas aujourd'hui dans votre
état civil un couple homosexuel qui se
marie il est inscrit qu'il est
homosexuel les choses changent
radicalement
vis-à-vis de la société dans son
ensemble est évidemment le monde de
l'entreprise bien évidemment donc les
choses vont avancer et le mariage pour
tous permettra je pense de donner le
dernier coup à je l'espère en tout cas
il va falloir attendre un petit peu
majeure envers moi j'entends votre
optimisme ce qu'on a entendu aussi les
téléspectateurs de public sénat viennent
de l'entente ce sont les mots prononcés
par
ces hommes et femmes homosexuelles en
entreprise qui disent en substance pour
vivre heureux et on heureux d'ailleurs
en tout cas vivons caché caché sa
sexualité vivre caché ça n'est pas rien
et ça passe parfois il l'expliquait très
bien par deux tout petits détails
je considérais que les colombes et
c'était un attribut homosexuels en tout
cas que les homosexuels portet et
j'avais comme ça des chocs complètement
interdites en termes de vêtements en
termes de couleurs on évite le parme on
évite le flashy voilà on évite plein
plein de chose sur lequel on fait
extrêmement attention
je me suis mis du côté de la meute en
disant oui dont celui-là quand même il
fait payer et c'est terrible parce que
pour s'intégrer à la meute on rajoute
presque nous aussi une sorte de couche 2
mo fogiel aux fruits ça me donnait le
sentiment d'être un imposteur par
rapport à leurs schémas et du coup ça me
donnait aussi ce sentiment d'imposture
par rapport à mon travail c'est à dire
que j'avais l'impression que j'étais pas
un bon commercial que que les succès que
j'avais je les méritait pas voilà donc
sacrés vraiment un complexe d'imposture
qui partait de la vie privée et qui
s'étendait complètement à la vie
professionnelle
ça demande une énergie folle de se
cacher non oui ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie et c'est pour ça que ces
personnages sont passés par des moments
qu'on était des vrais moments
existentielle je dirais de remise en
question c'est à dire que faire semblant
il ya tout un réseau de stratégie du
mensonge
à la fausse réponse c'est à dire combien
s d'une manière ou d'une autre et tout
ça extrêmement fatigant bien sûr vous
rencontrez les uns et les autres ceux
qui sont notamment engagées sur ces
sujets des gens qui vous dit je voudrais
bien le dire mais c'est pas possible et
pourquoi c'est si difficile pour cela
s'il faut je répondre à la question je
veux bien oui malheureusement
malheureusement aujourd'hui alors je
dirais que paradoxalement le robinet n'y
est pour rien entre guillemets mais le
débat sur le mariage était tellement
violent qu'il est était puissant effort
data démocratique c'est normal et moi
j'aime beaucoup de respect pour les
personnes qui sont pas à l'aise avec
l'idée du mariage là dessus ce n'est pas
un sujet en revanche les des propos
déplacés dégradant insultant très fort
très fort comme ce qu'on a pu entendre
une époque où lire au moment
effectivement de la grande bagarre du
pacs et du coup ça provoque un effet
encore plus
de recul de la part de ce corps est en
situation se claquemurent encore plus
jeunes mais évidemment avant qu'on parle
de prendre en compte et posent le projet
de loi vous aviez dans tous les sondages
qui était fait depuis deux ans vous avez
50 % de français qui étaient pour
l'adoption et 70% pour le mariage le
débat commence une force traditionnelle
de la société s'exprime plus violemment
et plus fortement qu une grande majorité
moderne ne le fait par ailleurs enfin
tout cas beaucoup plus fortement il
voulait exprimer exprimer mise à part
effectivement le milieu associatif lgbt
lesbienne gay bi et trans qui ont
vraiment pris la parole mais n'avait pas
le même pouvoir que lorsqu'on est épaulé
par des politiques ont pris
effectivement cette parole et du coup
ont déstabilisé une partie de ces
personnes qui était prête effectivement
à lui dire mais serait ce que pour
medicine un droit qu'ils avaient droit
parce que la question de la vie privée
ça reste un vrai sujet aujourd'hui la
vie privée c'est un élément moteur de
gestion rh ressources humaines la vie
privée il ya mes rtt mai jour de mariage
samarie la maladresse quand y aller
d'accord je dépose des jours de congé
moi qui a dû rentrer dans la boîte parce
que mon épouse prend ses vacances au
mois d'août donc il faut que justifie
que le petit nicolas vit avec sa maman
isabelle et sa maman catherine donc
c'est tout ça qui rend visible
effectivement donc ce dévoilement de la
sexualité en tout cas de la vie privée
dans les vide est une évidence et ceux
qui le nient sont effectivement
j'appelle ça la fout cutri qu'on a
aujourd'hui les entreprises à
dévoilement administratif à l'intérieur
entreprises qui paraît beaucoup plus
logique aujourd'hui une offre cas normal
on l'a entendu tv nord on entendu tout à
l'heure ce témoignage le dîner le dîner
professionnel et que les conjoints sur
moi j'ai servi d'alibi quelques bons
amis de haut niveau dans l'entreprise
j'étais vous avez convoqué parfois des
alibis vous même genre j'ai pas eu
besoin parce que c'est rapidement bien
qu'ils aient commencé ma vie en étant
hétéro donc dans la norme dite normes
j'ai très vite et assez à l'aise avec le
sujet parce que ça m'est arrivé plus
tard dans ma vie donc je les conçois
rebondir avec votre compagne et
mentalement oui bien sûr mais y compris
au travail en entreprise mais ça c'est
passé tout de suite tu avances que ma
compagne elle a subi beaucoup plus
lourdement les discriminations
christophe fall cause en quoi c'est un
risque et pour qui c'est le plus dur
d'ailleurs pour qui c'est le plus dur en
entreprise pour un homme pour une femme
homosexuelle je pense que effectivement
il ya la question gay lesbienne qu'il
faut quand même bien séparées
l'impression qu'elle accepte plus
facilement les femmes homosexuelles que
les hommes alors ça j'arrive à la pense
que l'on a eu la dent d'évidence que je
veux bien comment il peut y avoir plein
de stéréotypes derrière en tout cas
c'est des situations des vécus
différents quand on fait des enquêtes un
peu poussé sur la perception et c'est
très difficile de distinguer auprès des
répondantes lesbiennes le fait qu'elle
soit femme et le fait qu'elle est une
orientation sexuelle minoritaires en
fait il ya d'abord le poids de la
discrimination liée au genre qui la
fonde donc en fait quand on lit des
statistiques avec des répondantes
lesbiennes on voit d'abord des femmes
elles ont exactement le profil de femme
plutôt discriminés en matière de
rémunération en termes de carrière donc
donc du coup moi j'ai toujours considéré
qu'elle était sous le coup d'une double
peine le discrimination voilà que vous
dites a fait alors que les hommes c'est
un peu différent et puis après
effectivement il ya des mécanismes qui
sont relativement aux wikis sont
différents par exemple pour les gays il
ya toute la question
d'un stéréotype très fort qui est un gay
ne peut pas diriger des équipes il ya ce
côté un gay n'est pas tout à fait un
homme il faut un vrai homme pour manager
des équipes qui sont toujours considérés
comme des équipes d'hommes alors que les
lesbiennes vont pas nécessairement le
mettre en avant ce stéréotype elles en
ont d'autres donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
il faut se méfier de ce côté lgbt qui
ont fait un gros paquet on pense que
c'est une communauté il ya différentes
populations à l'intérieur différents
types de discrimination avec des
services et des mécanismes qui peuvent
être différents thierry laurent vous
venez de faire une étude qui est en
anglais j'en recommande la lecture
évidemment sur internet
sur le sur le coût d'un ajout thing d'un
coming out plus exactement parce que
être out et c'est quand vos collègues ou
ceux qui vous entourent 10 il est
homosexuel où elle est homosexuel et un
coming out c'est quand on décide de le
faire soi même ça coûte quoi ça se paye
alors la réponse se révéler
dans le sens de ce que disait christophe
la réponse c'est ça dépend parce que ce
qu'on a montré dans cette étude c'est
qu'il ya une grande hétérogénéité des
discriminations à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise y compris à l'intérieur la
population gay ou de la population
lesbiennes tout le monde n'est pas
d'exprimer la même façon et ça c'est un
résultat très fort que l'on obtient
puisque en fait le coup du coming out va
dépendre
fondamentalement de la question de
savoir si on est déjà perçu ou pas comme
gays ou lesbiennes dans l'entreprise un
peu beaucoup totalement quelqu'un qui
est
peut-être à son insu d'ailleurs
perçu totalement comme gays ou
lesbiennes dans l'entreprise le coût du
coming out sera très faible puisque en
fait la formation qu'ils révèlent est
déjà connu de l'employeur et des
collègues assurent également la
collectivité d'une certaine manière elle
est prête pas forcément assumer le
résultat elle est connue pas isolé et il
ya d'ailleurs un résultat intéressant
que l'on trouve c'est que la
discrimination salariale subie par un
gay
si les rucks il est connu comme gay
parce que l'employeur ne dépend pas du
fait qu'il ait été connue en faisant son
coming out ou qu'il était connu par
hasard parce qu'on le parce que
l'employeur l'a appris mais c'est quand
même différent c'est également la main
oui enfin vous me dites quand même qu'il
ya discrimination salariale jadis
nomination serveurs de la chiffrer il ya
une discrimination salariale on trouve
entre
six et demi pour cent pour ceux qui sont
donc affaires équivalent 1 c'est ça un
poste équivalent la différence entre
quelqu'un qui n'est pas père qui est
perçu comme certainement hétéro par son
employeur est quelqu'un qui est perçu
comme certainement un homo c'est à peu
près 6 à 10%
maintenant quelqu'un qui est père qui
est homo qui est gay ou lesbienne mais
qui n'est absolument pas perçu comme les
ou lesbienne parce que l'employeur la
discrimination n'existe pas enfin on
revient là si j'ose dire à la
discrimination traditionnelle entre
hommes et femmes qui existe là bien sûr
nos jeunes à l'art de salaire entre des
femmes poste égal qui lui existe mais on
n'ajoute pas si j'ose dire le facteur
sexuelle - ajout de l'orientation c'est
en fait à chaque fois que je parle de
discrimination qu'on parle de
discrimination on compare les gays aux
hétérosexuels hommes et les lesbiennes
aux hétérosexuels femme c'est-à-dire
toute chose égale par ça vaut pour les
promotions se disait tout à l'heure
christophe paul goze on ne promeut pas
facilement un ou une homosexuelle alors
on me nous on mesure la discrimination
on essaie de la mesure et on s'est calé
en moyenne dont 4,6 et demi au plus elle
est en moyenne de d'environ 4% sur les
données qu'on a pu récolter le le coût
du coming out je m'interrogeais là
dessus on l'a estimée en moyenne à
environ 4% de salaires donc pour vous
donner pour vous donner une idée c'est
un quart de l'épargné annuelle c'est un
quart de l'épargné annuelle une petite
affaire d'une personne qui est taxé
entre guillemets sous forme de
discrimination donc c'est loin d'être
négligeable
et c'est d'ailleurs comparable à la
discrimination de femmes puisque sur les
chiffres de discrimination une femme on
est en train aujourd'hui à
caractéristiques identiques et je fais
bien attention quand je dis ça parce que
toutes choses égales par ailleurs donc à
post identique c'est bien que le brent
l'accès aux postes
on a on est environ 4 et demi quatre et
demi 5 % de mes vous dit l'un et l'autre
il ya un plafond de verre pour le zénith
sexuelle oui on comme il est peut
exister pour les femmes oui dit ping
selling aux états unis
rose plafond
oui il existe alors je pense que les
lesbiennes le vivent en tant que femmes
principalement et les gays qui sont des
hommes ne le centaure regarde certains
et de la norme et donc du coup ont des
problèmes de carrière en tout cas dans
les enquêtes de perception c'est très
clairement avancé par les gais et on
peut revenir à la question par exemple
des dîners il ya des professions ou pour
faire carrière il ya la question de
s'associer il ya la question de
construire une vie sociale qui paraît
sera professionnel qui en fait très
important dans le jugement professionnel
et moi lors lalalalala l'enquète pour la
halle par exemple l'ex l'aixois le
défenseur des droits aujourd'hui j'ai eu
des dizaines de pages de gens qui ont
couché des témoignages très très fort je
me souviens d'un avocat qui voulait
devenir associé dans un grand cabinet et
qui a très clairement dit ben voila moi
je savais qu'il fallait à lire certains
week-ends qu'il fallait à certains de
soirée à certains dîners et donc alors
là il ya tout un tas de stratégie de
masques d'ailleurs que le documentaire
évoque 3g j'ai essayé de vraiment
d'analysé sur le fond elle les
sociologues le font depuis longtemps que
quelqu'un les gens parlent même de
complexe d'imposture voilà c'est le
terme est très très beau et du coup on
s'achète alors lui c'est un cc c'est un
élément de rideau on s'achète une
alliance avec une je vais parler pour un
gay avec une une ennemie eux et puis
elle va venir et elle va jouer la
compagne aux yeux du dirigeant et des
autres associés et ce type de masque
alors il y en a d'autres c'est vif très
loin de son lieu de travail parce qu'on
a peur par exemple de faire ses courses
avec son conjoint de même sexe et d'être
reconnus non dans la grande surface par
un collègue de travail qui créent ces
courses pas loin du lieu de travail donc
moi j'ai vraiment mis à jour plein de
stratégie de masse de ce type là qui
montre à quel point les gens sont
zhejiang les avec leur identité leur vie
privée pour tenir le travail à distance
et pour maîtriser le avec et quand ils
vont pouvoir parler d'eux en termes un
peu privé alors autre idée reçue il ya
des milieux où c'est plus difficile que
d'autres on va en discuter je voudrais
d'abord vous faire réentendre le
témoignage de ce gendarme il s'est pacsé
avec un homme en 2008 l'armée c'est donc
exactement avec qui il vit regarde je me
regarde dans un escadron de gendarmerie
mobile
on préfère voir arriver un gendarme qui
mesure 1 mètre 90 qui fait 110 kg cadets
bodybuildé qui fait du rugby plutôt voir
arriver un homosexuel moi j'ai un
collègue un jour j'étais en véhicule
avec lui il dit moi je m'en fous que tu
sois homosexuels du moment ne touche pas
le cul
ça j'ai entendu ça cent cinquante fois
en temps
ouais je suis encore énormément
sur une compétition sportive je suis
riom short c'est en été et puis une
officier il lui dit mon adjudant vous
avez un beau short de
je me taise qui connaît ma situation
ainsi qu'aux n'est pas ma situation
il est peut-être les homos forme parce
que ces gens c'est grave parce que c'est
comme si elles sont là on disait de vin
chante de ou dans un champ de
rabi d'un short de juifs pour moi c'est
pareil voilà et il raconte ensuite qu'il
a tourné les talons parce que dans
l'armée dans la gendarmerie quentin
supérieur vous fait une remarque vous ne
répondez pas c'est comme ça ça vous
choque bien sûr mais ça je pense que ça
choque les uns et les autres en plus je
suis frappé de voir quand même de quelle
manière il a intégré le stéréotype même
c'est à dire qu'il dit on préfère voir
arriver un rugbyman bodybuildé qu'un
homosexuel comme s'il n'y avait pas de
reçus à dimane le début des homosexuels
bien sûr et en plus l'armée et encore
plus normalisatrice que ne peut l'être
une entreprise savez quand on rentre
dans une entreprise dans un cercle avec
des collègues on rentre dans une
certaine norme celle que l'entreprise
évidemment vous impose qui n'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs celle de la société
même s'il doit pas y avoir on en parle
aussi à divers endroits dans le
documentaire est évidemment de l'armée
et encore plus normalisatrice donc
promouvoir et valoriser quelqu'un qui en
dehors du lieu de travail n'est pas tout
à fait dans la norme et a évidemment un
problème en soi
sur le lieu de travail alors ça pose la
question justement des milieux de
travail qui serait plus homophobe ou
même c'est la question que d'autres est
ce qui est intéressant de voir je pense
c'est que c'est beaucoup plus subtil les
contrastes et que cela en même temps il
ya des milieux de travail par exemple
comme l'armée dans lesquels il ya une
norme masculine dits traditionnels viril
il a donné une autorisation de tournage
quand même bien sûr bien sûr j'ai trouvé
ça assez courageux d'ailleurs c'est à
dire qu'ils aient la volonté je pense de
la part de l'armée de s'ouvrir à cette
question là parce que ici comme ailleurs
effectivement il ya du boulot ou encore
à faire est ce que je voulais dire c'est
que dans des milieux de travail plus
traditionnel où il ya une idée de la
masculinité plus tradi par exemple les
avocats les avocats le monde des
affaires dans le monde des affaires il
ya un certain nombre de codes d'en
parler christophe c'est à dire les
dîners d'affaires les dîners d'affaires
ce sont des dîners hétérosexuels pas mis
là je n'aurais pas mis chez les avocats
le milieu mais plus physique je veux
dire c'est très intéressant dans des
milieux comme ça où il ya une vision
masculine
traditionnels et les milieux de pouvoir
en entreprise en partie de ceux là
effectivement il ya des codes à
respecter et je voulais rebondir sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur ce
documentaire écrit à l'imparfait et pas
du tout écrit à l'imparfait en fait il
va regarder sur 50 ans qui s'est passé
pour voir effectivement ce qui bougeait
ce qui résiste mais on n'arrive vraiment
à des personnages qui parle absolument
d'aujourd'hui qui ont fait un coming out
ya un an deux ans trois ans pour les
autres et l'un d'entre eux travaille
dans un cabinet de conseil un cabinet de
conseil international etc et
effectivement il est confronté à cette
question des dîners sur de cabinet quand
on veut devenir partner partenaire du
cabinet il faut voilà il ya un autre
soit
associée dans le cabinet l'associé
effectivement prendre des parts dans le
cabinet alors il faut donner un peu de
son temps personnel ali dîner avec les
patrons et jean marie qui a fait son
coming out par exemple n'y va plus avec
une copine mais autour de lui de lui il
voit la pratique encore totalement à
l'oeuvre c'est à dire qu'à une norme on
dîne avec les épouses et donc alors bien
sa main beaucoup on in épouse
inexistante pour pouvoir faire un bel
équilibre hommes femmes à table j'ai
déjà entendu ça oui l'avons quand
l'alternance voilà c'est le protocole va
falloir le protocole par la loi
protocole de table un jeu par la
naissance ou de maintenant on va voir un
homme et une femme c'est effectivement
fautes ou des élections donc on va
commencer à progresser de regretter le
pouvoir au moins l'équipe de parité
c'est d'être point de vue en tant que
femme et non pas en tant qu'homosexuel
jeu quand même frappé par effectivement
cette son pouvoir te paraît tout à
l'heure effectivement la question de la
virilité comme l'évoquait christophe il
ya une culture effectivement
hétéronormée été rossés hétérosexiste
qui perdure et qui étaient ces milieux
pour moi le monde sport et pas un monde
très lent vers le les pompiers l'armée
la police et pas très ouvert encore une
fois idées reçues je voulais mais sur la
table monde agricole 48% des
agriculteurs trouvent l'homosexualité
inacceptable d'ailleurs le sondage
installé dans votre faim de vote dans
votre film ça correspond alors là vous
avez du machisme aux ailes du sexisme
vous avez de vos phobies
dès qu'on a une certaine perception
effectivement des voiliers de du rôle de
la femme du représentation de la femme
dans sa tente de milieu et je pense que
mon des pompiers n'en est pas exemple
loin s'en faut donc à leur vision qu'ils
ont des femmes n ses quelque vingt
pompiers brillante là vous avez des sexy
vous avez de mou phobie ça comme on
accole très souvent tout cas pour les
hommes homosexuels hommes le fait qu'ils
sont un peu comme des femmes ne sont pas
très costaud ce que j'écris soit tout à
l'heure à permettre à ce garçon bribes
bien maintenant il va pas réussir à
tenir l'équipe faut de la force et comme
on ne m'a pas effectivement une personne
handicapée ou une femme parce qu'on
pense il ya souvent dans l'entreprise il
ya la discrimination qui soit
involontaire on pense que ce n'est pas
possible pour la personne donc on va pas
le mettre en situation puisque milieu
d'hommes exactement et d'ailleurs cela
mais c'est pas un milieu homosexuel ou
la trompant son bien et c'est très
compliqué politique inclusif a voté tout
à l'heure ce mardi sur le dans une
entreprise c'est comment je fais pour
équilibrer avec mme eva critères
maintenant et il crée terme majoritaire
qui lui
l'homme blanc marié hétéro père de
famille bon milieu avec 18 diplômes donc
lui effectivement un grand pas dans les
critères discriminants unis ni arabe ni
africain ni ni homosexuel ni en dire
c'est sans handicap ni musulman ni juif
ni qu'atelier pas le brûler pour autant
non mais il est en fait le nom ce set
pas sur la représentation ou pas du tout
non mais je sais bien qu'il ya quelques
années au monde du débat du pacs des
élus présents de personnes ont défilé
vers une pancarte les au bûcher je
n'ose imaginer qu'on y faire une
pancarte les où les
bûcher mais on s'est permis de faire
commencer permis de tenir des propos
encore aujourd'hui récemment qui ne sont
pas acceptables donc laissons à une
minorité
d'une autre école il notre époque leurs
propos et appartements effectivement ils
sont ils sont d'evian la loi doit passer
par là et considérons que la société a
changé aujourd'hui que l'entreprise
change également d'entreprises et les
consuls comment mais le dirigeant de
deux coups un âge certain mais qui donc
sont notre génération or une élite qui
doit être renouvelée aujourd'hui comme
les dites politiques d'être nommé est ce
que est ce que d'ailleurs la loi passe
on peut revient la question des secteurs
et des métiers bien sûr alain dumont
faire la loi passerait à lisier alors
moi dans l' enquête que j'avais fait
pour pour l'aixois le défenseur des
droits aujourd'hui on n'avait pas
regardé la question c'est presque pareil
la question des secteurs de l'action des
métiers et donc les les
1433 répondants gays lesbiennes avaient
donné leur métier au moment où il
répondait donc c'est pratiquement la
même notion le secteur c'est plus la
vision de l'entreprise et le métier de
la du travail effectué par la personne
et ce qui était très intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement on voit qu'il ya des
métiers dans lesquels c'était beaucoup
plus compliqué pour d'autres et même que
les gays avaient tendance à aller vers
des métiers dits plutôt féminin c'est à
dire occupés majoritairement par des
femmes et les lesbiennes avaient
tendance à aller plus vers des métiers
dits masculins c'est à dire plutôt
occupés par des hommes donc les
questions de genre que évoqué catherine
tripon elle joue aussi à la question de
sexe orientation sexuelle cette question
genre est complètement imbriqués et du
coup mais elle est aussi intériorisée
par ces personnes et elles elles
essayent de de trouver une voie de
carrière qui vont leur permettre de
d'hésiter le risque d'être discriminés
paris est donc on avait aussi des
réponses très très clair plus de 40% des
répondants qui disait j'essaie de
trouver une entreprise dont je perçois
calais gayfriendly et des personnes
ayant déjà été discriminés qui avaient
des taux de création d'entreprises
beaucoup plus élevé donc je peux me
permettre de donner je ne réussis contre
clichés parce qu'une entreprise des
frais nîmes c'est parce que c'est moi je
connais les entreprises allez allez
savoir si une entreprise est gay
friendly avant d'avoir vu dans un bureau
six mois anne on en sait enfin en tout
cas en terme de politique aujourd'hui et
je moi je le conseille à mes étudiantes
c'est allé voir les politiques
d'inclusion les politiques diversité
regardez c'est sur tous les sites des
grands groupes au moins rester associé
si c'est non mais si c'est déjà écrit
d'accord et si une entreprise déjà mai
ouvertement sur son sens son extranet le
fait que la question de l'orientation
sexuelle est prise en charge qui a une
sensibilisation de tous les cadres ou
l'intégration si un signal et c'est des
gens qui sont très sensibles à ces
signaux faibles j'entends mais est-ce
que ça règle le problème
mais ça règle le problème est que la
voir écrire il rebondir se disait
christophe puisque nous avons très bien
nous avons travaillé avec mon collègue
ferhat mihoubi sur les salaires on a
aussi travaillé sur l'emploi et quand on
regarde
est-ce qu'il ya discrimination en termes
d'emploi d'accès à l'emploi entre des
hétéros et des homos on s'aperçoit que
toutes choses égales par ailleurs le
taux de chômage est à peu près le double
chez les gays que chez leurs homologues
hétérosexuels le double alors qu'on va
un peu plus loin mais on se dit mais
finalement c'est peut-être aussi des
comportements de leur part peut-être
qu'ils sont plus flexibles qui sont
vides plus souvent changer d'emploi et
quand on regarde ce qui se passe on
s'aperçoit que ce sont pas les les les
les personnes les plus âgées sont les
jeunes et on s'aperçoit que les jeunes
ou un taux de turnover très fort sur les
entreprises et les roms dans une
entreprise il acquitte iran dans une
entreprise il acquitte et c'est ça et à
chaque fois il repasse par le chômage et
c'est ça qui explique cette différence
de taux de chômage que l'on constate
entre les homos et les hétéros
donc c'était une question de
discrimination à l'embauché la cedh
jeudi un mode de comportement
jeune je dis pas forcément mais ce que
l'on constate c'est que ça touche
massivement les jeunes et que une des
explications de cette différence de ses
différents d'accès à l'emploi en plus de
ces je cherche le bon emploi et le bon
emploi pour un gay c'est pas la même
chose que le bon emploi pour un hétéro
le pôle emploi pour un gay c'est un
emploi dans lequel je me sens bien ça va
être un bon emploi pour un gay pour pour
un français noirs maghrébins ou une
personne sur deux handicaps c1 en
préfecture en jeu sont reconnus pour ce
que je suis et que le critère qui me
caractérise ne va pas est un élément
négatif
reconnu pour ce que je suis ou pas
pénalisés à cause de ce que je suis
c'est pas tout à fait la même c'est la
même chose tout à fait le même temps ces
deux côtés même si je reconnus pour ce
que je fais professionnellement alors ce
que je représente le suggérer déranger
parce que l'on peu gêné par le fait de
fréquenter un juif pratiquant musulman
pratiquant un homosexuel qui assume le
fait qu'il est marié
personnes handicapées avec handicap
lourd qui peut déranger des personnes
c'est la vie on est parent difforme au
nouveau fonds nécessite en et en tire en
est antisémite on est raciste ou sexiste
mais on n'est pas clairement dit fort en
revanche on a beaucoup de jeunes face au
handicap handicap physique qui dérange
donc quand on arrive à dépasser ça et
que l'environnement de travail que ce
soit les collègues de travail les
subordonnés si la personne concernée
elle même un rôle de management et bien
sûr le management au dessus dans
l'évolution de carrière s'il arrive
effectivement est reconnu pour ce qu'il
est et ses compétences et qu'on non pas
qu'on oublie mais on prend comme une
entité comme un élément voilà
aujourd'hui il est ce qu il s est pas
forcément ce qui m'intéresse je pas
forcément ma tasse de thé en tant que
manager n + 1 ou autre mais il est bien
donc voilà et la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que je n'arrête pas de dire et je
continuerai à lui dire quelqu'un qui est
bien dans sa peau c'est quelqu'un qui
bosse bien le d'aucuns vous le
traduirait par une bonne performance
pour l'entreprise est bonne pour le
salarié mais quelqu'un qui est bien dans
sa peau et la question des jouets bon
endroit mais perd aussi bien sur le pré
des terreaux c'est naturel il est dans
le code normal le code d'aujourd'hui
c'est incroyable très mal en entreprise
enfin je veux dire ils sont très bien
d'autres raisons ils sont très mal pour
d'autres raisons fin mai ils sont
hétéros la nouvelle génération de gays
et de lesbiennes devra plus manqué comme
ses aînés ils n'ont plus envie de sa
douce effectivement le turnover pour
trouver la boîte dans laquelle ils
pourront sans forcément se rendre
visible si c'est pas nécessaire mais
pourront le faire s'ils ont besoin si
l'on a droit à demander ou simplement
parce que l'on pose une question et puis
la vie au travail c'est un élément
important en tout cas pour ceux qui
travaillent en france vous passez 7h ou
8h au bureau vous en vendre des
relations de qualité de collègues de
travail on n'a pas de raisons de qualité
trente objets de mentir et l'enjeu
aujourd'hui est dans le dernier mode en
tout cas anglo saxonnes ont dit très
souvent outre ce tube on vous fait
confiance comment je peux faire
confiance comme je dis à ma boîte qui
peut me faire confiance alors que je
répondais craquer que tout le monde et
que je mens parce que je n'ai pas le
choix ou parce que j'ai pas de signaux
qui me rassure sur fait que je ne
resterait plus ou moins discriminée les
puisque vous venez de d'établir une
liste de discrimination ou plus
exactement de catégorie discriminer
handicapés
l'origine raciale
inscrits à l'origine raciale
le commission religieuse d'accord les
convictions religieuses qui s'est ajouté
maintenant à la race parce qu'on peut
être noir et ne pas disons être rejetée
pour ses convictions religieuses est ce
que vous êtes capable de me dire soit
christophe falco souhaite y rit laurence
ici les homosexuels sont plus ou moins
discriminée par rapport à d'autres
sujets de discrimination quelle est la
première cause de discrimination en
france au travail
sur les sujets sur lesquels nous avons
travaillé on s'aperçut que la
discrimination salariale
subies par les homosexuels hommes
étaient à peu près du même ordre que la
discrimination salariale subies par les
femmes vis-à-vis de leurs mollets à
l'orgue voilà donc c'est cet ordre de
grandeur donc tout se passe comme s'il
subissait le même type de discrimination
en terme d'ampleur pas forcément les
mêmes origines bien sûr mais en terme
d'ampleur ok mais est ce qu'on est
capable de dire la première
discrimination au travail ce sont les
handicapés alors on en fait une des
seules sources à laquelle on peut sur
laquelle on peut se baser c'est celle
des droits aujourd'hui compter les
réclamers donc de toutes façons la
moitié des réclamations reçues par le
défenseur des droits concernent la
sphère de l'emploi alors qu'ils traitent
tout le reste l'accès aux services
publics la voilà donc ça veut dire quand
même que l'emploi est un lieu de
discrimation très fort et les
réclamations sont très fortement sur
état de santé handicap sur origine
ethnique ces deux loin et des deux ailes
de discrimination fabrique pratiquement
la moitié des réclamations que le
défenseur des droits reçoit chaque année
et l'orientation sexuelle très peu alors
ça tient à la taille de ces populations
déjà mes skis et ski et j'ai eu une fois
une drh qui m'a dit ça ça fait dix ans
que je m'occupe des personnes
handicapées je le fais bien je crois
qu'elle faisait très bien son travail
mais je m'occupe pas de l'orientation
sexuelle ce que c'est une minorité
peut-être d'épingler entre guillemets et
donc je me suis mis 1
à jouer à un petit jeu du comptage avec
elle c'est la question de la mesure en
entreprise est souvent une question
essentielle pour engager un diagnostic
pour mesurer l'efficacité de ce qu'on
fait on veut mesurer et donc je lui ai
montré que si on considère qu'il ya peu
près 7 % de personnes lgbt en france et
bien il y en a un peu moins de personnes
handicapées qui sont reconnus avec leur
handicap au travail donc en fait je lui
dis bah tu tues tu es occupé pendant
très longtemps d'une minorité plus petit
tu as très bien fait et a laissé une
autre minorité un peu plus grosse de
côté donc là aussi il ya beaucoup de
représentations fausses on sait pas
combien ils sont on sait pas qui c'est
et moi je suis encore très souvent
devant d'aidé rage qui sont démunis qui
disent je ne sais pas qui sont ces gens
je sais bien combien ils sont je sais
pas comment m'y prendre il ya il faut
vraiment apporté ce que fait le
documentaire quelque part une histoire
une culture sur le sujet donc les gens
commencent à s'approprier et puis des
passes des stéréotypes qui sont
visiblement on pense éculés et en fait
qu'ils sont extrêmement actifs et on
voit que les les blés alors ce qu'ont
dit les patrons les managers le chef de
service par exemple sont en difficulté
face aux conflits ou des bas que ça peut
ouvrir au sein de l'entreprise gère
venir à la loi dite du mariage pour tous
qui a visiblement ouvert des plaies avec
une violence renouveler si l'on en croit
en tout cas ce témoignage là la pire
chose
quand j'ai pu entendre plus comme ça dit
comme ça au travail c'est après le
mariage gay qui évidemment il ya des
gens qui estiment qu'un homosexuel ne
doit pas se marier on parlait que de
nous ont parlé de nous parler de nous et
qu'il fallait exterminer
deux races les homosexuels et les juifs
donc je répondu en rigolant
bon les homosexuels je comprends mais
les juifs
c'était tellement dépité mais je t'ai 3
gens malades j'ai pas pu aller
travailler pendant trois jours
enfin j'allais voir le directeur du site
et je lui ai dit et il m'a dit on ne
peut pas être un départ tout le monde
j'ai dit non mais moi je veux que vous
convoquez la personne tous les deux et
vous fait un rappel à l'ordre parce
qu'il ya des lois de nos jours on peut
pas rigoler comme sa vie sur
l'orientation sexuelle la religion faut
vraiment il ya une place pour chacun
dans la boîte et je fais moi moi je fais
je suis en souffrance là je n'arrive pas
à travailler ça me il m'a répété couteau
on peut pas être aimé par tout le monde
monsieur le député où il ya des lois
visiblement on a du mal à les appliquer
à l'entreprise non on peut pas dire ça
0.5 fortement ce qui vient d'être dit il
ya des yade et il ya des freins c'est
évident en entreprise mais partout dans
la société je crois que c'est une
difficulté je pense que nous aurions pu
avoir le même témoignage dans des
services publics c'est dramatique
d'ailleurs mais c'est la réalité
parce que derrière la loi il ya
effectivement la perception sociale de
la société il ya
et puis à la volonté dans ce cercle un
peu fermé qu'est l'entreprise le service
de l'apli coûte pas l'appliquer de
s'exposer sur ce sujet là pour son chef
de service de s'exposer lui-même dans ce
débat-là danser sur cette question là je
veux pas y mettre alors qu'il est hors
veux pas m'avancer sim en dehors de ça
terrain guide pour moi c'est un très
mauvais calcul c'est un très mauvais
calcul
parce que je pense que justement
sanctionnables des caisses qui aurait la
tête sanctionnables de manière à
direction à la haine raciale ni
indirects qu'est ce qui s'approcherait
mais est-ce que ce qu'elle ne dit pas
c'est si elle est allée jusqu'au bout
c'est au delà de son de son arrêt de
travail si elle est allée jusqu'au bout
c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle a poursuivi ou
alors si elle à elle à elle à tomber les
bras et a finalement elle n'a pas ses
missions elle le raconte elle était
allée voir son supérieur hiérarchique en
demandant de sanctionner et lui a coupé
court en lui répondant on ne peut pas
être aimé par tout le monde et donc elle
s'est mise en arrêt maladie donc assez
mise en arrêt maladie donc l'avis ajouté
d'une certaine manière
elle ses protégés ainsi est donc là la
réponse de son manager on ne peut pas à
traîner par par tout le monde signifie
qu'il ya quand même une forme
d'acceptation et c'est là où il est
intéressant de réinterroger les choses
d'acceptation de l'homophobie dite
ordinaire qu'elle prend évidemment pour
une violence extrême et que d'autres
vont prendre pour une blague blague un
peu douteux on peut aller blague est à
peu près rien dit on ne peut plus
plaisir là quand même légalement cet
exemple est très clair loi de 1881 c'est
une diffamation et ça pourrait relever
si on est dans le champ du public du
privé de 45000 euros d'amendé trois ans
d'emprisonnement enfin les choses sont
très claires et en est aujourd'hui en
plus ça relèverait de l'incitation à la
discrimination puisque le propos est
quand même le dire on pourrait les
discriminer encore un peu plus lié à un
oubli de propos homophobes enfin il n'ya
pas des propos homophobes lien il ya on
est en france dans une société on n'est
pas aux états unis où tous les opinions
en partie dans la sphère publique ne
peuvent pas été tenues c'est la loi de
1881 et en plus effectivement il ya sur
six critères dont l'orientation sexuelle
un renforcement de la peine donc
juridiquement la situation il faudrait
la creuse et après je suis pas juriste
mais je fais souvent des formations
prennent manager là dessus juridiquement
la situation n'est pas très compliqué
c'est de la diffamation sauver c'est
strictement interdit moi ça m'est arrivé
en entreprises de traiter ces questions
là avec des juristes de traiter ces
questions la rue de dôme était d'aider
un exemple très simple un syndicat qui
fait un tract plus ou moins anonymes à
destination d'un autre syndicat en
disant c'est une bande de et la
direction des ressources humaines fort
heureusement très bien formés ces
dangers à nos deux fabricants
automobiles pour ne pas les citer c'est
immédiatement saisi son service
juridique et a fait une plainte contre x
on a très vite sud d'où venait le tract
pour arrêter tout ça et puis aussi pour
se protéger parce qu'à un moment si
l'employeur laisse faire le si procès il
ya ça sera la personne morale et ça sera
l'employeur qui sera qui sera attaquée
et là c'est du pénal ce que dit créé
savent est important mais la question
c'est ça remonte pas toujours au bon
endroit mais après j'ai creusé quand
j'ai vu cet élément et ce n'est pas
remonté jusqu'à la rh ou la télé sont
diverses mais ça qu'à un moment donné le
salarié ou la victime
comme chez des amis il faut le dessus
mais pour poser vous rendez compte mais
oui les gars c'est pour ça que l'on soit
bien le chef de service et alstom vous
allez passer par dessus la tête dudit
cela vous étiez vous au ciap à témoin la
raconter mais l'avais pas remonté
précédemment et et l'équipe rh la
découverte avec le film donc l'enjeu
aujourd'hui pour les entreprises c'est
d'abord un trait de sensibilisation
deuxièmement de donner les clés pour
permettre un salarié ou une salariée
d'aller au delà de son super héros chic
direct et de dire je discrimine à cause
d'hommes et d'oser lire et surtout
d'être prêt j'ai même si la loi préserve
effectivement les témoignages je ne sais
pas si un témoin ou pas à ce moment là
je passe en témoigner beaucoup de témoin
mais en tout cas elle la raconte à de
trois personnes qui n'ont pas osé en
parler on se bat diplôme donc ce travail
à faire de formation de sensibilisation
est donc le deuxième point nodal qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
sanctionne pas les comportements
homophobes comme on ne sait pas comment
gérer on fait rien donc on aura du mal
en sabre vendeur c'est un bon manager on
sait jamais qui blague d'agout n'êtes
pas un drame non au traité quelqu'un de
dire si longtemps tous et c'est
aussi agréable que de dire celle du pain
sané vous désolez ya pas de différence
la loi doit monter le curseur je suis
pas sur la loi
xu ping
et d'une certaine r je vais le large ira
tous les sujets qu'on a abordé c'est à
dire à la fois l'insultent le propos
discriminatoires mais aussi la
discrimination salariale de promotion ou
une embauche est ce qu'il faut comme il
ya des lois dites de parité d'égalité
salariale s'il faut une loi d'égalité
entre homosexuels et hétérosexuels crois
que le corpus législatif est suffisant
il faut qu'elle soit appliquée par tous
et partout c'est peut-être ça qui manque
et ce travail derrière d'accompagnement
qui est nécessaire et quand on ce combat
une discrimination quelle qu'elle soit
on les combat tout en même temps parce
que ce qu'on pourrait reprocher sur le
discours qu'on vient d'entendre et qui
fait froid dans le dos sur n'importe
quel la discrimination ils pourraient
avoir aussi un effet terrible donc
qu'elle soit sexuelle ou ethnique ou
religieuse peu importe donc quand on
combat une discrimination je pense que
c'est comme ça que doivent l'amant
général rhc services rh on doit tous les
combattre la seule différence c'est
qu'effectivement on a eu un un point
d'attention au printemps 2013 sur cette
question là de manière
paroxystique et c'est parti un peu dans
tous les sens sur la fin du printemps là
où le parlement sénat comme l'assemblée
ont décidé d'accélérer
l'adoption du texte le climat dans le
pays et est devenu extrêmement lourd
pour les homosexuels moi je me rappelle
d'une ligne parce que mal je vais lui
dire que ça va retomber votre pays ce
mois j'ai débuté la table optimiste
et très clairement je pense sincèrement
je fais le pari que
l'homophobie fin le l'ouverture du
mariage aux couples de même sexe est le
meilleur moyen de lutte contre
l'homophobie mais en même temps quand
nous avons en deuxième lecture à
l'assemblée
discuter dans un quartier totalement
cerné par les crs interdite à la
circulation avec les nazillons qui
étaient mélangés avec la manif pour tous
au milieu de mois je pensais aux
homosexuels qui regardez ces images là
et qui devait probablement même moment
dans leur appartement fermé la maison à
double tour et là j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'on avait terriblement régressé dans
le pays j'ai le sentiment que passé ce
moment là nous avons fortement
progresser nous progressons nous voyons
dans les sondages ailleurs l'acceptation
est encore plus importante qu'au moment
du débat donc je pense que comme tous
les pays ont fait d'ailleurs tous ceux
qui ont adopté le mariage pour le même
sexe dans leur législation les choses
vont avancer inéluctablement merci à
tous les cinq d'avoir été sur ce plateau
vous pouvez évidemment continuer le
débat sur le site sur l'adresse mail de
l'émission qui s'inscrit en bas de votre
écran ou sur les réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs hashtag docu débat la semaine
prochaine claire barsacq et un débat sur
l'évasion fiscale des multinationales a
très vite
bon